bueno
[Música]
y seguimos analizando todo este
conflicto con más romeros a la mar
gracias por estar con nosotros una
semana más en esta sección especial
haciendo un análisis de todo lo que ha
ocurrido en un corán y vamos a hablar
del conflicto en las regiones en tumbas
hablamos de onís y lugares que todo
empezó allí en el 2014 así raúl muy
buenos días seguimos explicando
distintas aristas de este conflicto
ucrania ahora todo está en guerra pero
las poblaciones de dónetsk y lugares que
ya conocen estos horrores desde 2014 son
8 años de conflicto armado entre los
separatistas pro rusos y el ejército
ucraniano si revisamos los mapas que
teníamos antes de la invasión porque
todo esto ha cambiado a raíz de las
últimas acciones rusas vemos que hay dos
regiones dones y lugares que quedan no
totalmente ocupadas por los rebeldes pro
rusos pero hay un tercio aproximadamente
que está bajo control de estos
separatistas en gran parte apoyados por
russian que rusia lo haya negado
reiteradamente sobre todo en lo que
respecta al apoyo militar que pasó en
2014 en 2014 hubieron esas protestas
europeístas en maldad cayó el presidente
yanukóvych y eso proporcionó un gran
rechazo por parte de estas regiones del
este que habían llegado a apoyar hasta
el 70 por ciento en las votaciones del
presidente de puestos de puesto hubieron
milicias voluntarios que ocuparon los
edificios administrativos de estas
regiones de estas ciudades y no sólo
también por ejemplo en mayo por una
ciudad de la que estamos hablando mucho
últimamente en 2014 abril se declararon
independientes de manera unilateral algo
que refrendaron en mayo también de
manera unilateral no según estos
separatistas fue un apoyo abrumador pero
no hubieron observadores internacionales
que lo pudieran corroborar y quien sigue
pues disputando esta cifra dicen que la
participación por ejemplo en estos
referéndums fueron de aproximadamente el
30 por ciento usted hablaba de quiere
derramar entonces le pregunto la
respuesta del gobierno ucraniano cuál ha
sido la que ha tenido claro pues después
de esta declaración de intenciones de
estas regiones las declaraciones de
independencias los referéndums el
gobierno ucraniano que en ese momento
estaba gobernado por petro poroshenko
lanzó una dura ofensiva militar que por
ejemplo logró recuperar mariupol pero se
queda en esas fronteras que veíamos en
el mapa anterior así se intensificó el
conflicto porque también del lado
separatista se aumentaron las ofensivas
y la defensa y eso precipitó una serie
de reacciones diplomáticas que
desembocaron en el primer acuerdo de
minsk en 2014 monitoreado por la
organización de seguridad y cooperación
de europa esto logró un alto al fuego en
principio para una mayor autonomía en
las regiones una serie de acuerdos
políticos pero hubo múltiples
violaciones por ejemplo la batalla por
el aeropuerto de dones que duró hasta
2015 y que ganaron los separatistas pero
pues con el coste de centenares de
muertos la destrucción de un aeropuerto
que había llegado a ser un aeropuerto
internacional y también pues así se
destruyeron esos acuerdos de paz de paz
de 2014 posteriormente 2015 según dos
acuerdos de minsk inia con la
participación de francia y alemania- se
negoció un estatus especial para estas
dos regiones que se retiraran las tropas
rusas que se celebrarán elecciones
locales y que hacia el gobierno
ucraniano pudiera recuperar el control
con la frontera de rusia pero pues de
nuevo se han registrado miles y miles de
violaciones a estos acuerdos acuerdo es
marc en este conflicto pues no se dieron
por ninguna parte si no no parece que
hayan tenido muchos impactos al menos a
nivel político pero si tenemos que decir
que las cifras de víctimas cayeron se
pasó de un conflicto armado que se
enfrentaban dos posiciones como en una
guerra abierta a una especie de guerra
de posiciones y de pequeñas escaramuzas
en total repasemos las cifras de
víctimas también desde ese momento se
han calculado unas 14 mil víctimas
mortales desde 2014 hasta la invasión
rusa más de tres mil son víctimas
civiles también han habido unos 7.000
heridos que son civiles y ha habido un
millón y medio de desplazados a otras
regiones de ucrania pero también a rusia
una cifra que ya se equipara
aproximadamente pues a la que estamos
hablando con esta nueva ofensiva rosa
todo esto sin contar el daño económico
una región que en 2013 había llegado a
aportar el 20 por ciento del pib de este
país y además el mar también le pregunto
ya hablamos los acuerdos de mick pero
porque nunca se pudo lograr un acuerdo
de paz real si pues hay muchos factores
pero a mí me gustaría destacar uno
especialmente que también hizo cuando
zelinski llegó hubo una especie de
esperanza quizás iban a tener posiciones
más dialogantes pero en ese mismo 2019
hubo manifestaciones en todo el cráneo a
favor de que como rechazo a los acuerdos
de paz es decir para presionar hacia
lenski que no aceptará estas estos
acuerdos que se habían llegado
aproximadamente el 12% de la población
de ucrania apoya estos acuerdos de minas
que es una cifra muy baja y en parte
estas manifestaciones también se
instigaron por grupos de voluntarios que
habían ido a combatir al donbass y que
es un sentimiento nacionalista ucraniano
que en ocasiones oscila hasta la extrema
derecha y pues es un sentimiento que
queramos no ha sido alimentado también
por este conflicto raúl de 8 años marc
le pregunto qué podemos aprender de esta
guerra en el donbass para este conflicto
actual en toda ucrania es que parece
también que el ser humano pues no
aprende de sus errores no aprende de la
destrucción estamos saliendo una
pandemia entramos en una guerra que más
pues efectivamente raúl para mí esta
gran lección este primer aprendizaje que
deberíamos sacar es que la población
civil estas regiones quedan en medio de
unos conflictos de intereses que al
final se cobra son vidas amnistía
internacional denuncia que en estos ocho
años de conflicto bando y bando han
perpetrado crímenes de guerra estamos
hablando de secuestros de torturas de
homicidios indiscriminados del lado ruso
por ejemplo también se denuncia la
existencia de fosas comunes de
separatistas pro rusos y de civiles con
al menos 295 cadáveres enterrados
entonces estamos viendo las
consecuencias de una guerra a largo
plazo que ahora amenaza a extenderse a
toda ucrania algo que no sería deseable
si el conflicto no termina pronto y
también finalmente vemos la poca
confianza que hay entre bandos no al
final estos acuerdos que existían que
estaban sobre papel nunca se respetaron
en ocho años de conflicto como se va a
lograr un acuerdo o un diálogo ahora que
el conflicto se ha intensificado tanto
pues mar gracias por estas píldoras de
sabiduría como dice nuestro jefe andrés
espinal es de todo esto que está
ocurriendo en el gran ya para entender
un poquito más muchísimas gracias además
por todo el trabajo que está usted
haciendo al respecto más gracias nos
vemos mañana con más nosotros pasamos a
hablar con este segundo invitado el día